30 minute workouts 20 minute recipes 10
minute mindfulness ready to become get
feel on the App Store or Google Play
hi guys welcome back I'm Joanna I was a
Terence and we're back again in the
kitchen and today is going to be an
Asian meal prep so thinking about some
base of mana yoga many ideas are there
will be four dishes okay
the first will be turmeric and lime
chicken the second will be five-spice
pan fried fish for the vegetables it's
going to be stir-fried mixed vegetables
and we also have my favorite soba noodle
and edamame salad so Terrence will be
dealing with all the meats and I'll be
prepping the vegetables okay so oh my me
to the sauna
I am to the negative T Rose here so
tyrannous AP euro is young attention
valiant Nicole mission to lesion a we
depart on my show material koyukon can
see you and honey ago so I'm changing we
now how 0
when it comes to Asian cooking we love
to use lots and lots of garlic so I'm
going to be slicing them because we want
to use it in the chicken as well as the
vegetable okay so now much here two year
old champion okay wait a moment yep you
know he wasn't in that time in shaping
and so Tapia really needs a pin through
the heart even somehow it was oh okay
it's taboo tomorrow a time of the year s
ho ho Tita we are here at I shop here
- what onions but I need to also has
treatment based on whether or not you've
been hungry so we're at heiser yeah okay
settle into the
so we're marinating the fish with
Chinese five spices and this physis
basically consists of citron pepper
cloves fennel seeds cinnamon as well as
star anise so there are lots of flavors
going into the fish right now Louella
take care no ha if I eat years it
doesn't hide oh sweet I mean ENSO vpg
beginning to do haha okay so now without
Year Zero Lola take you up on soon don't
be able to play this one ho sassy
yeah it almost went on putting lots of
it
garlic is so good to just bring out the
flavor of the food wait and then he's
going to also add lime juice as well as
turmeric and cumin powder so you can use
about one to one and a half tablespoons
of turmeric and cumin powder this will
give it a really nice spicy taste to the
chicken
yes yeah and it will make your chicken
look really good with that golden
yellowish look while he's doing that I'm
prepping the mixed vegetables which will
be lots of broccoli carrots bell pepper
as well as mushrooms
now for that extra zest taste we're
going to add about a quarter cup of lime
juice and as you can see we're using all
natural ingredients to really flavor the
food because when it comes to meal
prepping you want your food to taste
good and instead of just using you know
high calorie sources use herbs and
spices use lime lemon these are all
really good ingredients to marinate your
food and to really get all the flavors
in thank you - I'm terrified of withdraw
and I don't want to get my hands dirty
and yellow you know that he's gonna
handle that okay ketta monday is soup
and John but I have a seat here this
young lad amumu way the sauce it's young
and I'm sure when it comes to Asian
cooking we love to use sesame oil so
Chivas on k1 now although were you high
bother you or another
seriously past video chip you're beaten
yo yo yo Kayla didn't hang did all right
so we're good to start with our fish and
while he's doing that I'm going to cook
the soba noodles to make the soba noodle
and edamame salad for the soba noodles
I'm going to leave it for about five to
ten minutes until it's good but not too
soft
ah smells so good
I'm Sangha yeah you can really smell all
the five spices please young 22 mother
yeah
let me check all my soba noodles okay I
think it's done it's done right and look
at that it looks done yeah all right
so the soma noodles are done okay
cheapest um you know top who shot height
you do see myself society San Fran no
lovin John John back for chili going in
no way are you get 0 in the euro house
he was not had fun tonight 90 houses you
know GG van CBS or tengo cheap low to us
I'm Tyler James of that row cheer how to
do all that fun finally one fine day you
find narrows it when condition Ghana any
boxes so right now I'm going to let the
soba noodles to cool down before mixing
it with other ingredients and while
waiting for this to cool down I'm going
to start boiling the broccolis as well
as the carrots before stir-frying this
this shouldn't take long at all only I
would say 3 to 5 minutes because we want
to be cooking it again later on so it's
just to stuff in it so that it it takes
much quicker when you stir fry the
broccoli as well as carrots
even some hurlimann kind of matured as a
the boys about hey hey hey hey team
announces that means young but no matter
hater
it was only fun only times when I do
homework whether if I see a cop thank
you keep it up as a PI so that so see
you go oh hey hey shank well what's out
yeah okay okay keep eyes on Mahalo
mmm Sudama yeah yeah sure done wear your
suit ow I can smell this man yeah so
again when it comes to meal prepping you
always want to make sure that all your
food are fully cooked so you can't cook
it medium rare or things like that it
has to be fully cooked because you want
to keep it for a long time so veiny
tell you sir not the enormous
achievements and when certain time at
one time
so he was not eating out one chin so
what entry challenges it wasn't meeting
well Sarah aha medium so Virginia we
about harder you have to Marengo high
oshri but sojung about Peter - high
altitude got harder look at that crispy
skin
okay she shoulda y'all there you go
okay see that out
te rola Sochi dome for a second I know
you like a mega Tessa mean all have a
media film yo kind of nubia hot so the
chicken has been marinated for a good 20
minutes by now all the flavors are fully
absorbed into this chicken brown Wow
smells so good if only you can smell all
the different flavors going on right now
while he's doing that I'm going to boil
the carrots just to soften it slightly
before cooking it with the broccoli as
well as the mushrooms okay
so easy oh no way ouch ooh he didn't
look and Eurobeat here while you're
talking fighting so much
so it's you know Julia home yang tidak
10 I'm fine - fine times this is a power
Scylla it's it so the audience is Jim
she was out some kinda indeed back in
that zero Liu was a one champion by the
why not just tell Cara
Nina what to Pompeian t load up on the
other one crisis a PM by not a try
[Applause]
look at that golden yellow color now
that's that looks really good you can
really smell the turmeric as well as
cumin and again like like what we said
before you can also use these spices to
marinate your fish or even your beef if
you want to how look okay c1 is anything
holla
now that the fish and the chicken is
done we're going to leave them to cool
down and we're going to move on to cook
the mixed vegetables but before that
always cook your mixed vegetables with
garlic and again we're using sesame oil
juicer with a mouse young bother your
tongue right everything goes this one my
power yeah pour Clemens mesas tongue
Delta risotto apart you'll find a
threesome
all right I want some oils a bit I once
in a while or right now this is like the
secret not live a secret this is the
best ingredient garlic lots and lots of
garlic garlic makes everything better
so let's stir fry that until golden
brown before adding in the mushrooms the
bell pepper and the broccoli as well as
carrots so say you found a hole you need
no medium you'd be time using solder
yeah
did you have each other oh yeah take a
mobile thanks without her - I gotta see
what yeah and the reason why I prefer to
slightly boil the carrots and broccoli
is so that it will quicken up the
cooking process because otherwise it
takes too long to soften the broccoli
and Karen as well let's cover this right
now and allow this to cook for 3 to 4
minutes ok this should be done those
young yeah now that the mushrooms and
bell pepper has softened we're going to
add in the broccoli and my favorite
carrots you want to be generous with
your vegetables okay it as much
vegetables as you can this is a huge
portion and now just very little soy
sauce
okay okay top buttons yeah yeah Tina and
a little bit of spring onions Chinese
love their food spicy
hahaha oh we're good to add a little bit
of chili flakes as well
just to bring out the spice more more
okay more yeah more loves it city house
yeah so it's really quick as you can see
this is really quick less than five
minutes
everything is done and we're going to
transfer it into this dish and allow it
to cool down all right two dishes done
but one done and the final one we're
just going to mix all the ingredients
together that's involved
there you go mixed vegetables and now
just allow this to cool down this is my
favorite I love soba noodles so what
we're going to make here is soba noodles
and edamame salad so I've mixed my soba
noodles with a little bit of sesame oil
to avoid it from sticking and now I'm
just going to add all the ingredients
into this bowl so we have about half a
cup of edamame all right edamame is very
high in protein especially for those of
you who are vegan or vegetarian add more
edamame into your diet spiralized
carrots okay and then I'm going to add a
little bit of spring onions right just
very little a little bit of sesame seeds
and again we love spicy food so one more
chili flake say okay and not forgetting
a little bit of soy sauce as well so do
it you are able to begin kind of rough
correct it is high in sodium therefore
you have to limit the amount of soy
sauce you use in your cooking and now
just mix it all up you wanna help me do
what I do so this is actually good for
two to three servings he doesn't eat a
lot of carbs therefore for him he tends
to eat very small portion of this and I
love noodles I love soba noodles
especially and now just a little bit
more spring onions for the garnish thank
you and a little bit more chili flake
it's done now that all the four dishes
are done and they've cooled down we want
to transfer them into individual
containers and take it out with us on
lunch as well as dinner great I don't my
finding take a top boys or teeth eating
yeah but having long legs in reality
once you know that way but I know how he
told ya this is a double in the hour sir
how are you
so we're separating the fish the chicken
the soba noodles as well as the mixed
vegetables and you want to make sure
that when you transfer it into the
container that the dish is really dry
avoid adding liquid into the dish when
it comes to meal prepping you want to be
very clear on your portion so are you
prepping just for lunch and dinner or
are you prepping for three days it is
very important because then depending on
how many days I'm you're prepping for
you want to make sure that the
ingredients you choose can last for a
long time in the fridge the yogurt noir
inversion medium medium juice or
maintenance a girl
what for so after dom0 to medium duty to
what we sorta Sankyo recently what we
made him go to so you're ready waiting
it's the Kuya and all see ya his routine
when he gets up in the morning
the first thing he has to do is to cook
yeah
you can't he will not even get out of
his house or arrange any appointments in
the morning before he gets to cook
because this is his priority basically
when it comes to you know having a good
physic and things like that yes
exercising is important but what you is
place at least eighty percent to your
physique and therefore whatever you put
into your body should be number one
there's anything to know that it's an
easy it isn't she here who's a bootable
innocent
example now the house exactly so yeah so
Walker and may idiot is wrong syndromes
it so I know the house for mine
yep and be adventurous keep
experimenting with different flavors and
different ingredients as well if you're
new to meal prepping then start off with
really simple ingredients just like what
we have here to meats really simple
mixed vegetables and once you're
comfortable with this then you can
continue and try different needs
different vegetables and different
cooking methods as well
gende Anwar brother puta eating down
Iran and the reason why we want to
encourage everybody to start cooking for
yourself because then you know exactly
what you're putting into your body and
how much you're eating in a day
therefore whatever your goal is whether
it's to lose weight whether it's to gain
muscles you're able to achieve that even
quicker and more efficiently as well we
have sliced a couple of limes here and
I'm just going to put it together with
the chicken and right before you want to
eat your chicken you can squeeze a
little bit of lime just to avoid the
chicken from from being too dry
you're just get out will ya Danny fun
thank you so you just want you like to
be out though yeah this is our Asian
meal prep done we have turmeric and lime
chicken five-spice pan fried fish mixed
vegetables as well as soba noodle and
edamame salad and we also have a little
bit of nuts as well as fruits as our
snacks
I've been waiting to try this
how's it it's good yeah
right join a trial it's a bit of chicken
good hmm whenever Yugoslavia whenever
you cook for yourself somehow you will
appreciate the food more as well
you can get all the recipes in the
description box below including the
calorie count as well as the
macronutrients if you enjoy this meal
prep if you want to watch more meal
prepping sessions with parents and I
then be sure to give us a thumbs up like
this video and subscribe to our YouTube
channel the warm and a pink power we'll
see you next time let me know which is
your favorite recipes in the comments
below
[Music]